the archbishop of san francisco has
informed nancy pelosi that her public
support for abortion constitutes a grave
and mortal sin and therefore she is not
to receive holy communion until she
repents confesses her sins and receives
absolution as the church has taught
consistently for 2000 years
but the self-styled devout catholic
nancy pelosi has rejected her bishop's
instruction just as she has rejected
other essential non-negotiable teachings
of the church to which she allegedly
belongs
pelosi's behavior has left many people
confused
which is why we are so fortunate to have
noted theologian and doctor of the
church whoopi goldberg to help clear up
the finer points of catholic theology
the abortion rights battle is starting
to blur the lines between church and
state the archbishop
of san
um
francisco
calling for speaker nancy pelosi to be
denied receiving community because of
her pro-choice stance he's one of the
priests who also called for president
biden to be denied sacrament this is not
your job dude
that is not you can't that is not up to
you to make that decision okay we have
to stop right there we will get to the
rest of what she said but we have to
stop there because
maybe whoopi is confused or i don't know
that is literally his job
that that that it is his job to make
that decision
that is what a bishop is that's what a
bishop does
whoopi goldberg might not know that
because she's not catholic no one is
really sure what whoopi goldberg
believes she has said that she feels
jewish
which would explain why she took a
jewish stage name but she her name is
not goldberg that's not the name she was
born with i think it's johnson
she's not jewish she doesn't practice
judaism nevertheless nevertheless
she she
a fake jew is now going on to
pontificate on catholic eucharistic
theology
what is the saying it's kind of amazing
uh
but
you know
what is the point of communion right
it's for uh sinners
it's the for the for sinners it's the
reward of saints but the bread of
sinners how dare you
how dare you that is if pope francis
says that that's the issue now despite
whoopi's slam poetry and regardless of
the media's favorite one-liners from
pope francis that's not what the church
teaches
the church teaches and has always taught
for 2000 years that before receiving
holy communion catholics must confess
our mortal sins and we must repent and
then confess and then we can receive
communion sometimes we sin we don't make
it to confession on those sundays
faithful catholics choose not to receive
communion
because if we did we would in the words
of saint paul be eating our own
damnation now listen
you might not believe any of that
you might not believe all of it you
might not believe any of it nancy pelosi
might not believe all that
whoopi goldberg might not believe all of
that okay
no one is forcing these people to be
catholic
if they think that it's all a bunch of
baloney
why are all these libs so insistent that
pelosi be allowed to receive communion
in a state of unrepentant mortal sin if
they think that the church is wrong and
not just wrong but wrong on essential
teachings unchangeable teachings like
the teaching on abortion
then why do they care so much about the
catholic sacraments
the answer is clear
leftism is its own religion
abortion is its sacrament
and the libs want their blasphemy
blessed i'm michael knowles this is the
michael noise show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from aaron stanger
who says
i'm still waiting for the murder hornets
i know i know it was easy we were so
afraid of
kovid and then omicron and net
neutrality repeal and now the monkey pox
and the global warming it was easy to
forget that we were also all going to be
killed by the murder hornets but yeah
the murder hornets never really
materialized
nor did the sun monster nor did
you know the the
17th variation of kovid that was going
to wipe out the earth none of those
things happened now we all brace
ourselves for the monkey pox and when i
brace myself for the apocalypse you know
i'm going to do it in style that's why i
wear my mizzen and mane right now go to
missin and maine.com use promo code
knowles i absolutely love these guys
missing in maine has
not only extremely soft comfortable
fabrics they've got really chic designs
they just look cool i wear mizin in
maine i feel like i'm ready to go walk
in the south of france or something it's
it's very athletic so you're not going
to sweat through it especially if you're
a perspiring italian like myself they've
got the fit and style of a custom dress
shirt polo shirts dress shirts oxford
shirts lightweight breathable moisture
wicking
they will have you looking great and
feeling great and then their dress
shirts are machine washable
you skip those trips to the dry cleaner
you save a ton of time you save a ton of
money
msn and maine might have gotten famous
for their dress shirts they now also
have incredibly comfortable flannels no
tuck shirts performance polos it's
probably my favorite performance polos
chinos they have everything i love these
guys and most importantly of all the
style looks amazing whether you are
working from the golf course or finally
taking advantage of that unlimited
vacation policy we've got good news
right now if you go to mizzonmain.com
use promo code knows you'll save 35
bucks off any regular price order over
125 bucks that is 35 off when you go to
m-i-z-z-e-n-a-n-d-m-a-i-n.com
use promo code knowles
i don't want to bore you with catholic
theology i do have to correct what
whoopi goldberg is saying and i know
that it's probably the biggest news
story going on right now because you
finally got pushback against the speaker
of the house of representatives on this
essential question of abortion biggest
topic in the country right now but i
don't want to bore you with catholic
theology if you're not interested in it
you don't have any desire to become
catholic or practice the faith or
anything like that so then why do all of
these non-catholics take such a big
issue about it
why why does whoopi goldberg care
what is pelosi here what is joe
scarborough here joe scarborough
very much not a catholic just took to
his soapbox on msnbc to excoriate the
catholic church for
enforcing its 2000 year old teachings
this past weekend the san francisco
archdiocese has banned nancy pelosi who
we're having on the show tomorrow
speaker of the house from receiving
communion she's a staunch catholic uh
but because of her stance on abortion
they've banned her we'll be asking her
about that but this is this is where
we're going with all of this a lot of
opportunities for the democrats but a
lot of challenges
mika the catholic church really the
priests in the catholic church really do
have
a lot of room to stand to stand on their
high horse and be self-righteous towards
parishioners who have been faithful
parishioners for decades who actually
stayed with it through a a a crisis
where priests abused
thousands and thousands of children and
past children around from one church to
another church from one diocese to
another diocese it went all the way up
to the top and they
are being self-righteous and telling
nancy pelosi that she can't take
communion they should thank god that
nancy pelosi has remained a catholic
through their torrent of of the most
grotesque sins imaginable
the catholic church should thank god
that nancy pelosi
an unrepentant
sinner who is flouting the essential
teachings of the church
is violating the instructions of her
bishop because
of the sex scandal in the church which
obviously was real but as studies have
shown
sex abuse is no more prevalent in the
catholic church than it is in any other
religion and it's certainly no more
prevalent than it is in the secular
leftist society it's actually much less
prevalent children are much much much
more likely to be sexually abused by
teachers in public school than they
would be by a catholic priest the
numbers are not even close and
furthermore
why does joe care why is joe getting so
worked up about this
why is he getting worked up about
a bishop of a church that he does not
believe in
enforcing the teachings of that church
the consistent 2000 year old teachings
on one of the parishioners
on one of the other
nominal members of the lay faithful
again the church that joe scarborough
does not belong to of the faith that he
does not believe in why is he why are
all the libs
so bizarrely obsessed with nancy pelosi
being able to
break the rules of the catholic church
and in such a way that will actually
harm her mortal soul if the catholic
religion is true
this is the question for me with pelosi
this to me
i think dispels all of the
media contrived pity party for nancy
pelosi here
why does pelosi so badly want to receive
the communion in a state of unrepentant
mortal sin
if
if
the catholic faith is true
then what the archbishop is doing is
helping nancy pelosi it is for her
protection
and we know nancy pelosi just when she
went to mass in dc on sunday she
received
holy communion
in contravention of what the bishop of
san francisco her home her home parish
said
but if
if
if nancy pelosi does not believe in the
catholic faith if she thinks the
catholic church's teachings on abortion
which go back 2000 years which remain
unchanged and according to the catechism
unchangeable you can never change it
then that means that nancy pelosi thinks
that the faith is false if nancy pelosi
thinks the faith is false why does she
care about receiving the sacraments she
doesn't believe in the sacraments then
so what's it to her
if on the other hand she believes that
the faith is true
then surely she should follow the faith
and the faith is true on this
unchangeable essential teaching on
abortion and she should repent because
she's imperiling her soul she should do
what the bishop is telling her to do
because the bishop is trying to help her
the catholic faith is true or false you
know i think it's true
maybe nancy pelosi doesn't
maybe you don't
whether it's true or not
whether nancy pelosi's faith is sincere
or insincere
the the craziest thing about this whole
controversy is that there is no
circumstance there is no combination of
any of those things in which pelosi's
actions are justified
it's so
so i i wondered to myself why why is she
so insistent why is joe scrub rule why
are would be gold why are they so
outraged by this it is because you're
seeing a real conflict of religions here
christianity
versus leftism
and it's a battle between these two
faiths a battle between these two
churches
and
and what the libs are demanding what the
pro-abortion people are demanding
is that the catholic faith surrender
and christianity broadly surrendered
that's what they want
abortion is the sacrament as peter
creight says abortion even uses the same
words as the holy communion this is my
body except to a blasphemously opposite
meaning and what the libs are the reason
that all these non-catholic liberal
people heretics systematics apostates
all these people the reason they care so
much is that they
are insistent
that their blasphemous sacrament of
their unholy religion of leftism be
blessed by the
spiritual authority that's existed for
2000 years
got to protect ourselves folks when you
want to protect your home you've got to
check out ring right now go to ring.com
knowles you know how much i love ring
these guys have been with us almost
since the very beginning of this podcast
you know about their video doorbell i
hope you have it by now if you've got
the video doorbell you can see and speak
to whoever is on your doorstep whether
you're in the home outside the home on
the beach on the other side of the world
then they've got ring alarm this is this
whole home protection to keep track of
your your windows your doors your
everything the physical home
now they've gone pro
that's right cnet calls ring alarm pro a
giant leap for home security because it
protects your physical home and your
digital home you spend so much of your
life
digitally virtually it protects your
wi-fi router your data it's just great
it's a whole home protection from freeze
fire flood the bad guys and
all those people who want your data with
a ring protect pro subscription which is
a great deal by the way you get
professional monitoring for the ultimate
peace of mind if anything happens
professional monitoring will call you
and can request emergency services i
totally love these guys i totally trust
ring they make me feel much more secure
in my own home to learn more go to
ring.com knowles ring.com
knowles
cnn's dana bash has taken arguments for
abortion
to a really really new level
you know the libs are they've tried to
make some religious arguments they're
really going after the catholic
arguments right now they're they're
trying to insinuate that pope francis
somehow is pro-abortion which is not
true pope francis says abortion is
murder and uh it's comparable to hiring
a hitman to kill your enemies so okay
the religious arguments that's not gonna
work for the libs so now they're moving
to economic arguments cnn's dana bash
just had the governor of arkansas asa
hutchinson on
who is pro-life and dana bash
made the argument that
if we
get rid of roe v wade if we outlaw
abortion
there might be more poor people
arkansas already struggles to support
vulnerable children nearly one in four
children in arkansas lives in poverty
more than 4 600 kids are already in your
state's overlaid overloaded foster care
system do you really think
that your state is prepared to protect
and care for even more children
if abortion does become illegal there
that argument that dana bash is making
to asa hutchinson could be reduced to
three words
kill the poor
that's what she's saying that's she's
saying that's what we're doing right now
she's saying thanks to abortion
poor people
can have have the opportunity to kill
their children before they're born into
the world and and go on the public dole
and we the taxpayers have to support
them so they have that option now to
just kill the poor
while they're still cute little babies
and they don't grow up and take too much
money from the taxpayer so governor
hutchinson if we get rid of abortion are
you really prepared
to feed the poor
are you really prepared to
to let the poor live
asa hutchinson who's kind of a squishy
republican a little bit dumbfounded
there though
dana is that really the argument you're
making that really is the argument
that she's making that's i remember
these arguments because i used to make
them when i was a teenager because i
read those stupid freakonomics arguments
and all the fashionable liberal
arguments and this is what they come
down to they say you know look people
born in the inner cities you know they
can become criminals these are not great
areas so let's just places where the
abortion rate is kind of high let's just
keep it up because it's going to reduce
the crime rate it's going to reduce
welfare spending
that's why we need to kill innocent
little babies is they might come up to
be sort of a burden to us
that is really evil thinking
that is when you think about it in the
light of day that is really some evil
stuff and it's so selfish and that's
what this whole abortion issue comes
down to
selfishness versus charity
no matter how you slice the abortion
issue comes down to my selfishness
to have sex whenever i want without
consequence my selfishness to control my
own body at all times and not be
inconvenienced at all even if the
alternative is killing an innocent
little baby the selfishness to pursue my
own whims and desires and career and
never sacrifice anything not even for my
own child the selfishness to get to keep
all of my money and not have to feed my
little baby and not have to clothe my
little baby not to put my baby in school
the selfishness to to be able to pick up
at a moment's notice and drop every
responsibility in the world that's all
it comes down to me me me
all through the night i me my i me my i
me my rights
never do you hear any argument for one's
obligation to one's own child never do
we hear how how wonderful the sacrifice
is anyone who's a parent out there
listening knows that having kids
requires a lot of sacrifice you
sacrifice your sleep first of all you
sacrifice your body certainly if you're
a woman you sacrifice a lot of your
money you sacrifice a lot of your time
you might sacrifice part of your career
and you sacrifice all these things
and it's wonderful
you wouldn't trade that for anything in
the world it's so but we don't we don't
talk about that
or you don't i'm sorry we don't hear
about that from the pro-abortion
movement they seem not to understand
that
what is the pro-life argument the
pro-life argument doesn't deny that
you've got to sacrifice things the
pro-life argument doesn't deny that
pregnancy is inconvenient and
uncomfortable sometimes pro-life
movement doesn't deny that kids take a
lot out of you
but the pro-life movement just says it's
worth it we don't we talk about the
right to life but more we just talk
about our natural obligations more we
talk about charity more we talk about
what it what it means to to have
responsibility to our fellow citizens
and especially
to our kids
totally foreign to the people on cnn uh
gosh if we let if we don't kill these
babies in the womb they might be poor
and icky and yucky
then we'll have to we might even have to
pay for them so awful speaking of
poverty
speaking not caring about our fellow
citizens
56 of san antonio retailers reported
being completely out of baby formula
last week
local news outlet reported that parents
in san antonio
are struggling the most in the united
states to get formula that their babies
need with 56
of retailers reporting empty shelves not
just that the supply is low
totally
empty
this is a failure of national policy
this is part of the reason by the way
why the democrats are hemorrhaging
support right now
because the democrats are for and the
elite republicans too but especially the
democrats the democrats are focused on
transgenderism in schools the urgent
national need to chop off kids genitals
and put them on puberty blockers the
urgent national need to stop the sun
monster climate change that's the most
pressing need the urgent need to stop
oil contracts in alaska and elsewhere in
the country so that we can have more
electric cars the urgent national need
to get involved in the war in ukraine
that because of the russian invasion of
ukraine a conflict that's going been
going on for a thousand years the urgent
nationality to put everything on hold to
the urgent national need to let millions
of illegal aliens cross the border and
then by the way ship baby formula down
to them before american citizens get it
and regular american citizens all around
the country of every race color
or country of origin they're looking at
this and they're saying what the hell is
wrong with you people
a national policy
that does not address people's
basic needs not that
not the need to mutilate our bodies to
pretend to be the other sex that's not a
basic need it's not a need at all
actually not the need of people to redo
all of their automobiles so that you can
go along with your sun monster
cult
that's not a basic that could even have
some enhancement to society in the
future i don't think it will but maybe
it could but it's not a basic need food
money
shelter these are kind of basic things
jobs these are basic things and the
national policy is not addressing them
national policy should be aimed at the
common good of citizens this is really
basic stuff
joe biden used to get this joe biden
used to understand this he joe biden
15 years ago
certainly joe biden 20 years ago talked
like
a republican today there was a clip that
was going around of joe biden i don't
know how long ago was probably about 20
years ago joe biden talking about
marriage talking about the issues that
the american people should be talking
about he sounded kind of like a
republican
we are desperately concerned about the
circumstance relating to
avian flu we don't have enough vaccines
we don't have enough police officers and
we're going to debate the next three
weeks i'm told
gay marriage a flag amendment and god
only knows what else i can't believe the
american people can't see through this
we already have a law the defense of
marriage act we've all voted not where i
voted and others said look marriage is
between a man and a woman and states
must respect that
nobody's violated that law there's been
no challenge to that law why do we need
a constitutional amendment marriage is
between a man and a woman what's the
game going on here
it's like looking at a different man
it's like one because he's
semi-coherent and it can at least form
english sentences there
but two because he's saying things that
are mostly normal now i don't want to
sound like i'm complimenting joe biden
too much he was always a hack
and he was just trying to distract from
good conservative priorities here the
conservatives at the time were trying to
pass a constitutional amendment to
codify the definition of marriage
because they knew that the supreme court
would get kind of funny with things and
overturn the defense of marriage act
which is exactly what happened and joe
biden here very disingenuously or at
least very stupidly is saying that that
would not happen
but just listen he's talking about he's
saying look everyone's afraid of
catching this flu well we need to go out
there and stop people from catching this
flu
we need to uh we need to make sure that
we take care of the basic needs of the
american people
not talk about these extraneous things
that no one cares about
that guy's gone so how did joe biden who
used to be a somewhat practical guy used
to be somewhat more moderate used to
talk to really basic issues how did he
become this current guy the problem for
joe biden is he doesn't actually believe
anything so obviously he's changed his
view on marriage he's changed his view
on abortion he's changed his view on
anything on anything that is convenient
for him he wakes up in the morning licks
his finger puts it in the air figures
which way the wind is blowing and then
that
determines what he is going to believe
that day
and the problem for that is
you you you're never sturdy on anything
if you if you have a political vision
that's sort of systematic and you've
really thought through things then even
during tough times you'll hold firm you
might pull through you're you're leading
your country in in this case joe biden
he because he doesn't believe anything
he can't lead at all and so he's gonna
blow where the urgent popular wins go
and that almost always leads you to
disaster just look at the economy right
now look at immigration look at foreign
policy look at look at
everything in the country right now and
look at joe biden's poll numbers you see
if only he could get that guy back if
only he could get back to being even
somewhat almost possibly a little bit
reasonable
but he can't he can't and so when we
want to plan for the future
we really need to make sure
to look into alto ira right now go to
alto ira.com michael do you own any
bitcoin ethereum cardano
do you own some other cryptocurrency if
you don't and you're not sure where to
start you have got to check out alto ira
that's that's where you start do not
make mistakes other people make mistakes
when they just try to do crypto on their
own alto offers alternative investment
opportunities like private companies
crypto funds real estate venture capital
and more alto ira in particular is a
great way to start investing in trading
in crypto here's the key with a tax
advantaged retirement account no
commissions no paperwork alto makes
investing in crypto incredibly easy
create an account in just a few minutes
and invest with as little as 10 bucks no
set up charges just create your account
transfer funds and start investing
through altos integration with coinbase
you get secure trading 24 750 plus
available coins on their interface
including bitcoin ethereum cardano alto
offers industry-leading security the
advanced encryption standard for wallets
and private keys they've got lots of
terrific investment opportunities and
multiple ways to fund your wallet open
an alter crypto ira account with as
little as 10 bucks go to alto ira dot
com slash michael that's
a-l-t-o-i-r-a-dot-com
michael start investing in
cryptocurrency today
as you know by now the event of the
summer backstage live at the ryman
auditorium is back on june 29th it's at
the ryman in nashville tennessee due to
historic demand we have opened up some
more tickets to the event so there is
still time to get in on the fun and
watch your daily wire hosts live and
unfiltered what is backstage live like
well i'm glad you asked check it
the famous ryman out
it was amazing we were in the presence
of greatness the energy of having
everyone on the same page was amazing if
your family member is still waiting for
fauci to give them permission to leave
their house it might be time to cut that
off
i'm actually pretty excited to meet all
of them i love everybody's opinion
individually i don't have a favorite i
like them all i had found out a way to
make football players cry in high school
my high school experience would be a lot
i'm just excited to be here and be
surrounded by like-minded people and to
just you know feel that energy who
should we remove from office yeah one
politician the most powerful politician
in the country dr fauci
we're doing culture here i'm so thrilled
to see this happening if they say to
half of the country you can't that half
of the country needs to say screw you we
will
backstage live happens right here in
nashville on june 29th get your tickets
now
this year we're going even bigger so get
your tickets for backstage live today at
dailywire.com ryman you will not want to
miss it we'll be right back with a lot
more
it's not just biden the entire democrat
party leadership is so thoroughly
dishonest and we don't always find it
out for sure at the time
sometimes it takes a little while months
or years to have definitive proof of the
corruption of these democrats in
particular i'm not letting republicans
off the hook totally but the democrats
are a lot worse it's just the way it is
it's just a fact well we finally found
out something that those of us with two
brain cells to rub together have
suspected for six years now
who do you think was behind the russia
hoax who do you think was behind it
was it the russians behind it was it the
british was it the fbi could have been
was it this was you know who it was it
was hillary of course it was hillary it
was hillary all along and we suspected
it and we knew it in our heart of hearts
and the media said that's a crazy
conspiracy theory that's crazy you crazy
kooky conspiracists you think that
hillary is behind every problem she's
the boogeyman nope do you know how i
know that hillary was behind it because
her campaign manager just said so
hillary's campaign manager robbie mook
just testified as a witness in special
counsel john durham's trial of michael
sussman
michael sussman who is the lawyer
accused of lying to the fbi about this
whole russia hoax
in september 2016
michael sussman took claims of a secret
donald trump connection to the russians
to russia's alpha bank
to the fbi so it's not just that he took
the claims to the press it's not just
that he took these claims to twitter
he took them to the fbi
and then he lied he said he was not
acting on behalf of any client
that was not true he was working for
hillary he was doing it for hillary
so robbie mook
along with hillary's policy advisor jake
sullivan who is now the national
security advisor for joe biden
along with jennifer palmieri the coms
director for hillary along with john
podesta the spirit cooking campaign
chairman for hillary
gave this cooked up nonsense to a
reporter
hillary was personally asked about this
and personally approved it the story
then appeared in slates laid as a
left-wing website the left-wing website
naturally didn't do any due diligence
didn't do any actual investigative work
on this they just took the clinton
campaign's claims as gospel truth
then on halloween 2016
mr sullivan issued a statement
mentioning the slate story saying quote
this could be the most direct link yet
between donald trump and moscow then
hillary tweeted jake sullivan's
statement statement with this comment
quote computer scientists have
apparently uncovered listen to that word
computer scientists have apparently
uncovered a covert server linking the
trump organization to a russian-based
bank
now in true clintonian fashion
you could argue she didn't technically
lie here because of that word apparently
and it it appeared that way it was
apparently so because the clinton
campaign was lying about it so it's true
it did kind of appear that way it's just
that they set the whole thing up it was
completely fake news and hillary herself
directed it she was at the top of the
whole thing
and also in true clintonian fashion
they're saying this is old news what the
clintons always do and other democrats
have learned to emulate this
they lie lie lie lie they keep getting
accused they lie lie lie lie they keep
there's new evidence they lie lie lie
finally it's proven that they actually
did what they said they didn't do and
then they say it's old news
they said what are you talking about oh
come on that's from 2016. yeah but
you've been lying about it since 2016.
yeah nah man water under the bridge
whatever
whatever come on move on
move along
the whole thing
the central event
that
basically undermined donald trump's
presidency
that cast his entire presidency is
illegitimate this grave threat to our
democracy that the libs always love
talking about
was just completely cooked up by hillary
clinton
and then fed
illegally to the fbi
that was it it was all hillary
and robbie mook just spilled the beans i
feel bad for robbie mook
something tells me robbie mook is about
to have a real bout of depression you
know
he's i don't think he's ever been
depressed before but he might he's gonna
end up really depressed
and i hope this doesn't happen but he
might end up you know
sadly
uh suiciding himself with seven bullets
in the back of the head and a couple
cinder blocks on his feet and down at
the bottom of the east river that
has been known to happen to people who
cross
hillary clinton watch out for any
suspicious fedex men
robbie do not watch out if you even if
if the person's got a mustache and kind
of groucho glasses if they've got those
arkansiding kind of eyes to run run in
the other direction robbie please
now
this actually brings me to a place a
little bit of a side note but go with me
for a second
you know i usually
make fun of the view and those cackling
hens on the view because they they do
express views that are very popular on
the left but they're completely
incoherent well
in fairness
because a stopped clock is right twice a
day because i try to be as fair as i can
to my opponents joy behar said something
the other day
that really struck a chord with me that
is that is completely true and it's on
this point
of snitching of disloyalty
npr doesn't want the covet to spread
yeah so they're telling their people if
you're a fellow employee sitting there
without a mask i want to hear about it
report it to hr i think i would never do
that on italian we don't snitch
because snitches get stitches we don't
sniff look i think it's a good thing
because
we've been terrible to each other during
this uh pandemic i i think you know
remember patty lupone was was uh at the
theater and she had to really dress
someone down yeah a theater goer and
saying you know protect us we're here
without our mass our audience is all
mass because you guys are protecting us
because we cannot be masked right now um
and i think you know there are times
when you want do you see someone let's
say on an airplane when we had the the
mask mandate and they had the mask
basically you know around their ears
like earrings or like chin guards and if
you said anything they would fight you
about it and this the flight attendants
had to say stuff so i i just think you
have this this mechanism now where you
can just call
and snitch
and protect yourself so
i love what joy behar said here i never
thought i would utter that sentence but
i love what she said she said look i'm
italian we don't snitch
snitches get stitches totally agree
loyalty is very important discretion is
very important
rats rats are no good don't be a rat so
i'll give joy bay her the point but then
just as joy behar makes this the first
good statement the first true statement
ever uttered on the view sunny hostin
has to come in and completely knock it
down
and she says yeah but no snitching is
good in this case in the covid regime
it's really good
she says you remember just this was now
a couple of weeks ago patti lupone the
broadway performer she had to dress down
an audience member because she was up
there talking without a mask on just
like we are here at the view we're
enjoying our lives we're not wearing the
masks and
whenever joe biden or kamala or liz
warren or nancy pelosi or dr fauci
himself whenever they thought they were
off camera they weren't wearing their
masks but then they insisted that you
all wear the masks all the time but look
she had to dress someone down because if
the dirty filthy peasants don't put on
the masks then us good people
were we might catch their germs and then
she i could i couldn't believe this this
broke news as far as i'm concerned
the audience at the view is still
wearing the stupid masks she says look
look you dirty disgusting horde of
peasants out there watching this show
you have to cover up because we don't
want to
and we're good we're the good rich
people and we're on tv and so we
shouldn't have to
but you have to
and so you do it to protect us we're not
protecting you
you're it's like on the airplanes and
then i love she uses the example of the
airplane she says on the airplanes a lot
of the times people wouldn't wear their
masks right
that's true that's true i was that
person i did not wear the mask right on
the airplane i had it down all the time
i would take the three hour long sip of
coffee so that i didn't have to put the
stupid mask on a lot of people did the
same thing and guess what
covid didn't spread on the airplanes
they all told us it was going to spread
on the airplanes it didn't happen it
never happened
and now they just lifted the mask
mandate and you know what it's fine
everyone's totally fine
it's amazing that these libs always draw
the opposite conclusions
from the evidence that they're
presenting
the masks on the airplanes
i think pretty clearly at this point
did not do a whole lot to stop the
spread of kovid and lifting the mask
order hasn't done much just to kick off
the spread of covet it was a dumb policy
the whole time
just like my favorite my favorite one my
favorite version of this is when fauci
and wallansky and biden all said if you
get if you take this vaccine you will
not get coveted you will not contract
covet and you won't spread it to others
and that's and then what happens the
vaccines don't do either of those things
people who get the vaccines get kovid
they spread covid
and then they say they say well no but
like it's really i got coveted i have 17
booster shots i i actually i'm just
hooked up to an iv of covid vaccine and
i did come down with kovit i currently
have covid
thank goodness i got my shots it would
have been so much worse and i know
why do you think it would have been
worse well because all those people who
were wrong about what the vaccine would
do they told me so
because all those people who have been
lying to me for two years shamelessly
they told me that that's true so i
believe them
[Music]
give me more shots please dr fauci
that's what they're telling us that's
what sunny hostin seems to believe a
rare win for joy bay be in this case be
like a joy behar do not be like a sunny
host and i think most people know this i
don't think people want to snitch on
each other anymore i don't think people
are living in terrible fear of the kovid
monster i don't think unfort some of us
got it a little sooner than others if
you're listening to the show you
probably understood
a little earlier on during covid that
wait a second this is really seems a
little bit more like a political power
grab than it is a health measure okay
but some people eventually they got it
even some of my liberal friends and
family they finally kind of got it and
just as everyone is finally kind of
getting it what are they doing
they're promoting a new pandemic there's
a new panda that would be the monkey pox
and there
there are two stories on monkey fox
right now as to how this came about the
first one is frustrating
the second one may be even scarier so
the first one is
that this past february there was some
research published on monkey pox
this was published in the scientific
journal virologica sinica
and it said that scientists had mapped a
part of the monkey pox genome to be used
for detecting infections
it described the monkey pox the symptoms
as a dna virus with two manifestations
and it really went in depth mapping out
the monkey pox
guess which institute of virology
published the monkey box study
two syllables
pretty close to a bat market you know
that's the one that's right the wuhan
institute of virology so you think man
these can't these guys lay off for like
two seconds can't take a few years off
wuhan institute of virology but look i
don't know
that
this is
the case i don't know that that you know
the wagon institute had anything to do
with monkeybox actually there appears to
be a more likely explanation as to where
the monkeypox pandemic
began
it appears to have begun
at a belgian fetish festival
and an adult sauna super spreader event
in spain
now
the these headlines you're going to see
a lot of headlines like this they're
actually being a little politically
incorrect
in both cases they began at gay orgies
that's really what it is but because the
newspapers don't want to be called
homophobic or whatever they're trying to
hide that so one of the gay orgies was a
belgian fetish festival uh
that described itself as open to the
entire
belgian gay community
i forget the exact name of that festival
and then the other one was a yeah we
don't i don't have the name of it here
that's fine i suspect you're not looking
forward to attending
uh then the other one was at a gay bath
house in spain
and so uh one of the chief medical
analysts
for the uk health security agency this
is dr susan hopkins says the community
transmission is largely centered in
urban areas and we are predominantly
seeing it in individuals who identify as
gay or bisexual or other men who have
sex with men
it doesn't seem like there's a ton of
distinction between these three groups
but what they're saying it's basically
it's gay men and gay men who are in
denial are the ones who are
who are contracting this thing
people who act out on same same-sex
attraction okay and not not all gay guys
it's just you know but the ones who go
to orgies uh have a greater likelihood
of spreading this virus and immediately
there was a doctor at yale
who said do not hold on do not let the
spread of this monkey pox turn you sex
negative dude sex negative is the term
that is no hold on do not stop it do not
make sure you keep going to orgies is
what he's insinuating just be a little
bit more care as though we are so far
gone in our political radicalism we are
not even permitted to say hey guys
with the kind of dangerous monkey virus
spreading around maybe lay off the gay
orgies for a little bit we're not even
allowed to say that so far gone is our
decadent culture
speaking of our decadent culture
speaking of allegedly liberating
experiences
will smith just had an episode of david
letterman's new show come out will
smith's episode was taped before
the slap heard round the world before
the oscars when he went up and smacked
chris rock for telling a completely
innocuous joke about will smith's wife
in this interview with david letterman
will smith describes this premonition of
possibly losing his career possibly
losing
everything and he got this premonition
because he had what what he is
describing as a kind of religious
experience but it wasn't an ordinary
religious experience it was because he
was high on the drug ayahuasca
stop drinking i'm sitting there and then
all of a sudden it's it's like i start
seeing all of my money flying away and
my house is flying away and my career
has gone away and i'm like ah all right
i'm trying to like grab for my money and
my career my whole life is getting
destroyed so this is your fear this is
my fear i'm in there but i'm in there
and i'm
wanting to vomit and all of that and i
hear a voice saying this is what the
[ __ ] it is
this is what the life is and i'm going
oh [ __ ] and i hear willow screaming
daddy help me daddy how come you won't
help me and i'm like i don't see you
baby i don't see you and the shaman is
like relax relax relax and she totally
sits up she tells me sit up and then
slowly i was like like i stopped caring
about my money i just want to get to
willow stop caring about my house i
stopped caring about my career and
i get to the point where
i settle down and the voice is still at
100
i still hear willow screaming my money
is still flying away but i'm going
and i'm totally calm even though there's
hell going on in my mind when i came out
of it i realized that anything that
happens in my life i can handle it i can
handle
any person i lose
i can handle
anything that goes wrong in my life i
can handle anything in my marriage i can
handle anything that this life has to
offer me
that's part of the psychological
training that happens in ayahuasca if
that's what the psychological training
of ayahuasca is promising will smith
i think he should ask for a refund
because it didn't work did it because
not only can will smith
quite evidently
not handle anything that comes in his
marriage or his professional life or
anything else he can't handle an
innocent joke from a comedian about his
family during an awards show about his
wife about his actress wife his public
figure wife he can't even handle that
without losing his mind and i don't mean
just to beat up on will smith
this is what happens when people
do a lot of drugs and do lots of crazy
behaviors and engage in that kind of
stuff things go bad i have so many
friends
who have gotten into psychedelics and
they really love psychedelics they've
tried to get me to do them i've never
been interested because i don't want to
break my brain you know i'm not the
brawniest guy so if my brain breaks then
i'm kind of screwed you know and i said
no no i i don't think i want that they
said no man you get these really
spiritual experiences i said i know i go
to church so i get i get plenty of
spiritual experiences i really and i
know that those are not coming from some
chemical that's breaking down my brain
matter but uh from something a little
bit higher i would like to think so no
thanks no thanks i don't i don't want
the drugs and
every person i know every single one who
has gotten into psychedelics
has ended up worse for it
every person i know who's really gotten
into the psychedelic stuff
has ended up the worse because they have
done it and they all think they're
better they all think they've seen
something but they haven't
or maybe they have seen things but i
don't think they're seeing good things
i don't think you know when that voice
is screaming this is what the effort is
i don't think that's an angel yelling at
you if it's not just a hallucination i'm
not sure it's an angel that's yelling at
you daddy daddy where are you sorry
honey i can't find you i'm super high on
drugs i'm tripping out of my mind right
now so i can't find you honey this is
not
the thing that responsible people do
this is not the way
to find some meaning in your life
people are drawn to this because it gets
us right back to what we were talking
about at the top of the show
people are drawn to
psychedelics
and even extreme diets
and even
a really extreme kind of
physical exercise like yoga they're
drawn to yoga not just because they like
to stretch
but because they want meaning
they're drawn to yoga because yoga is
actually a religious liturgy it's a
religious ritual they're drawn even
something as plain as an extreme diet
very often they're they're they're drawn
to that because it's more natural it's
more in tune with the earth the way
we're supposed to be the things we ought
to do and they're especially drawn to
drugs for this reason
and most especially the hallucinogenics
the psychedelics because they think that
they have a religious longing
that's totally normal that's totally
natural man is a religious being
but you're not gonna you're not gonna
get the right answers that way
you are not going to fill that gaping
hole in your heart that you're longing
for with all that stuff
you're not gonna some people try to fill
it with politics and they turn politics
into their their greatest ultimate
crusade
you're not going to fill it with
politics either i'm not saying get out
of the political realm
but you you don't want to put the cart
before the horse which is what which is
what pelosi is doing which is what all
these guys are doing
they're saying i
my
chief
object of worship is my own will is my
own desire it's what i want and
ideally that goes along with religion
and custom and culture and all this
stuff but if it doesn't damn it if i've
got to choose between my own will
and
my faith what i say is my faith my will
is going to win and i'm going to make my
faith bend toward my will
me me me what i want what i want to do
me me me all the time that's what it is
that's what it comes down to
which is not
just not a good thing before we go just
a little side note speaking of drugs
we're approaching the anniversary of
george floyd's death
and just to remind you that the fake
news that surrounded that event and that
kicked off eight months of race riots
and terrorism around the country
just to remind you that that's not over
the washington post has tweeted out on
may 25th 2020 george floyd was shot and
killed in police custody
his death sparked outrage wide scale
protests and goals to change policing
two years later what has or hasn't
changed you know what hasn't changed the
washington post spreading fake news
because obviously george floyd was not
shot ever at all in police custody
outside of police custody that's just
completely fake it's totally made up
they've since stealthily edited it and
they won't admit they did anything wrong
this was on the page they put that line
on the page where they elicited reader
responses to how they feel about george
floyd
these myths
these are these now religious myths in
the the secular religion of leftism of
blm of saint george floyd of al all of
these things these are
the myths that will be propagated with
the mouthpieces of this establishment
and they're going to keep pushing it
that is their faith they have got the
zeal of a crusader okay and it's it's no
surprise
that when your religion contradicts them
they're coming after your religion i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knoll show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bori supervising producer mathis glover
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer danny d'amico
associate producer justine turley audio
mixer mike coromina and hair and makeup
by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
bickley here daily wire editor in chief
wake up every morning with our show
morning wire where we bring you all the
news that you need to know in 15 minutes
or less
join me and my co-host georgia hal for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire